[Applaudissements]
oh c'est lourd
oh j'avais tellement peur de tomber de
vous montrer mes fesses
c'est pas ce que je voulais dire je
merci beaucoup j'arrive pas à y croire
on parle de la Saint-Valentin il y en a
beaucoup qui trouvent que c'est
marketing etc mais c'est mort pour moi
l'égrégore de l'amour c'est une belle
énergie d'amour je suis tout à fait
d'accord avec vous bon après ça c'est
vrai que ça peut quand même créer une
forme de pression sociale etc mais puis
on n'a pas besoin d'une d'une journée
pour aimer et mon nous vivons en
attendant pas que la mort nous donne du
talent comme disait un célèbre
philosophe aux cheveux longs ça vous est
déjà arrivé de recevoir des courriers de
fans et d'amour et
oui ou pas un amoureux
on l'a tous en politique l'amour et le
des amours
politiques ont un pouvoir sur les gens
d'une manière générale et sur les femmes
en particulier je crois très très
important la politique plus que les
hommes ou les femmes politiques c'est la
politique qui attire vos précieuses pour
la Saint-Valentin c'est prévu non donc
c'est open vous avez deux jours pour
inviter Priscilla pour la Saint-Valentin
elle a pas dit que c'est open
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ça date de loin mais nous on aimait bien
faire des soirées à thème donc
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
on avait un frigo à vie et une femme à
vie c'est ça
au
Réfrigérations
donc c'était fais-moi coulisser
l'andouillette dans le cresson ou des
trucs comme ça quoi
les anecdotes aussi précises comme ça
ça fait 10 ans que vous cartonnez depuis
baby-sitter et pendant pas mal de temps
ça ne marchait pas vous n'arriviez pas
[Rires]
ils ont fait la version porno
dans le mariage de mon meilleur ami vous
souvenez quand Cameron Diaz elle chante
ah oui oui
[Musique]
[Rires]
c'est une autre chanson qu'elle chante
mais peu importe en tout cas
en premier j'ai beaucoup de fluidité moi
j'ai 68 ans et Lola elle a 40 on a 28
ans d'accord rien rien n'est choquant
ici une balade dans la rue tout ça un
autre tu changes un paramètre je vais en
Espagne qui est le pays de ma femme
monsieur en Espagne les gens me
regardent comme un vieux vicelin
milliardaire qu'est-ce qui exhibent
à l'époque autant de au tout début de
slam quand il y avait des des problèmes
techniques informatiques et qu'on était
plantés pendant une demi-heure je disais
allez deviner de quelle couleur est mon
caleçon et donc ça alors franchement je
ne sais même pas est-ce que vous voulez
que je vous le montre il est bleu
coquinette il était temps quand même
j'ai récupéré le rôle de responsable du
camp je m'occupe de l'approvisionnement
nos et du ménage je suis doué pour ça je
peux me mettre à l'aise
[Musique]
ok il était possible c'était des lois
quand j'ai des gaz je les évacue si
possible avec une belle explosion j'aime
faire du bruit en fait je fais des
jambes
avec des professionnels de service à la
personne donc ça révèle que si une mère
au foyer percevait un salaire celui-ci
s'élèverait à plus de 6400 euros par
mois
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
merci je suis très ému parce que
c'est peut-être la dernière fois ce soir
que je vois un public maclamé debout et
c'est même certainement la dernière fois
ce que vous savez
j'arrête les frais
mon corps ne peut plus suivre je ne veux
pas chanter assis je refuse cette
éventualité comment pouvez-vous laisser
à une heure de grande écoute Laura de
l'air se confier sur son comportement
plus que limite dans les EHPAD je vous
propose de découvrir la séquence en
question pour faire ce documentaire j'ai
beaucoup pété aussi dans d'autres
maisons de retraite
alors je vous rassure Muriel Laure Adler
ne loupe pas sur des personnes âgées il
s'agit évidemment d'une liaison entre le
mot beaucoup et le verbe
alors voilà
mais une raison d'être
très élu ce soir et de vous remercier et
de vous remercier vraiment et de vous
dire peut-être à la folie je t'aime à la
folie je t'aime à la folie je t'aime à
la folie je t'aime à la folie je t'aime
à la folie la vie
[Applaudissements]